(light music)
- [Jamie Hall] As we look ahead
to an all electric future,
we really talk about not
leaving anyone behind.
(light music)
- The San Joaquin Valley in California.
It has some major challenges.
It's got some of the most severe poverty
and the worst air quality
in the entire United States.
(light music)
- The transportation industry
is really at an inflection point.
We've got to fundamentally transform
this whole sector of the economy.
And this particularly
includes the communities
that are hardest hit by climate change.
(light music)
- What Valley Clean Air Now is looking at
is how we bring climate equity
to the places that need it most.
- There's a lot of need and
people rely on these vehicles.
(light music)
- [Tom Knox] At our event here today,
we've got hundreds of people
who need help with their small repairs.
When we look at transitioning
into an electric vehicle future,
it's important to remember,
it's not there for everyone yet.
(speaking Spanish)
- The older, the vehicle,
the higher the emissions are going to be.
So we've offered them $850 in repairs,
which typically fixes the vehicle.
(speaking Spanish)
- [Tom Knox] We're also going
to educate them on the fact
that we can help them
replace their older vehicle
with a used electric vehicle.
(light music)
- [Jamie Hall] We need to
figure out how to do this
in a way that provides
benefits for everyone.
And doesn't leave anyone behind.
(light music)
- Right now for electric vehicles,
they're so new that we don't have enough
electric vehicle
technicians out there yet.
- I've always wanted to learn this.
It's the future for me.
- [Tom Knox] The only way
to create those technicians
are really passionate expert instructors.
- When the opportunity arose
to work with Valley CAN
in order to develop this
training, it was a no-brainer.
One of my passions is
helping students transition
from education into the workforce.
- The market is growing quickly.
We need to really grow the pool of people
who have the skills and knowledge
to work on electric vehicles.
- I feel like this class is going to be
a solution to a big problem.
The change is going to happen fast,
and it's exciting that I'm
getting my foot in the door
to learn about that change.
- There's this mentality
out there that I've noticed
where it's almost like people
consider these to be UFO's.
They're still vehicles.
It's all stuff that's held
together with nuts and bolts.
It's just the technology that propels it
down the road is different.
- Having this class means a lot, you know.
It gives me an edge in
this growing industry.
It's going to help myself and my family.
- This is no longer car mechanics
as we used to think of it.
This is more a technology job.
This new generation of
electric vehicle technicians
in 5 or 10 years, they've got
enormous career opportunities.
They are going to be
the hands-on innovators
that really make electric
vehicles work for America.
- There is an opportunity out there
if you're willing to take it.
And doors will open up if
you're willing to take a chance.
I want to be a part of that change.
(light music)